mary cosby i got one question two ways
where you've been all my life and where
you've been in these last couple
episodes of salt lake city
i mean people want more mary how do you
feel about the reception to you
i don't know that people want more mary
however i want more mary
um but it wasn't oh how can i say this
without
giving like you know being blunt they
kind of tried to
fade mary out and didn't know mary was
going to be more wanted
but a whole different situation there's
been a number of group
events on the show that you didn't make
it to
did you feel left out or were you happy
to not be at those events
i was so happy but honestly i was so
happy like
every escape was
like literally escaped from me i was
going like
ah especially when i didn't have to go
to vegas i was so happy
i was so really because i didn't want to
be in trouble you know i didn't want to
like
i want to divide by the rules but i just
no i didn't feel left out
and i was at peace very much no fomo no
fear of missing out from mary cosby no
laugh with me
now i'll see you when you were on watch
it happens live
you let it slip that you had not been
keeping up with watching the episodes
you said do i need to watch the episode
i'm saying you need to watch the
episodes before the reunion prepared
check your email because you're all set
all the episodes so i want you to
i won't i didn't know that yeah yeah
yeah did you take him up on uh his
advice did you watch the episodes
i did watch the episodes i did get
busted on not watching
you have seen them now what did you
think of the season did anything
surprise you that you went
oh hey i think what surprised me is when
i wasn't on there and
the spark that comes with me
is that bad i mean that's what you're
supposed to say
i yeah that's what surprised me is like
my absence
i was like okay well it's clearly there
so
after watching did you feel prepared for
the reunion how was that reunion let's
just say that
there will be a part one two and three
there's a lot
okay there's a lot to get into
what surprised you about that day about
filming that reunion
i think what surprised me is some of the
behavior
of a couple of the girls
and the apologies that
rolled out surprised me and
the the progress and and like
productiveness that came out of it i was
very surprised by that
the fans went a little crazy when the
cast photo came out and you and jen
are side by side smiling next to each
other
is that a sign that peace was brokered
at the reunion
i would take it as a sign that something
was broke
and it's safe to say that says something
more than a pr it says progress it says
progress okay
you said there were apologies made did
you get any apologies from people
i did i did did you have to make any
apologies
of course of course yeah
well you know there's this this whole
saga of
did meredith and lisa tell you
that they are afraid of jen or not
that has to be unrevealed i'll put it
this way
does mary cosby lie no i do not
lie i back what i say uh it could mean
not like oh
she's the boogie man's gonna beat me up
but it can mean like
she's supposed to be your friend you're
not brave enough to say that's not okay
yeah i asked heather about this and her
interpretation was
everyone's a little bit afraid of jen
because you never know how she's going
to react
when you talk to her about some tougher
topics
except me i'm not going to you know
invest myself into
a person that's not giving me what i
deserve
and i know my worth as a friend i'm a
true friend and
jin may be one okay progress has been
made
it doesn't doesn't sound like we're back
to a friendship place but maybe we're on
the road
there well i'm real so whatever i say
i i need to own it i don't think
everyone is able to
move forward with damage that's been
done with
personality flaws or whatever cases
so there's progress there there will be
resolution on the lisa meredith front
resolution um yeah
it'll clear everything up all right it
cracked me up
you posted your glam for the day and
your caption said
didn't like my makeup
why didn't you like it i just didn't and
i felt like i didn't have a choice of
the matter of who did it and
i felt like it was important to know i
didn't like my makeup you have to start
using apps for your picture
and start you know start like smoothing
this out and like evening your eye like
then you know you didn't like your
makeup so then you just post it it's
like tell them i didn't like my makeup
yeah that's that okay i love it this
refreshing honesty i think is what has
won
over the viewers this season
i don't think anyone likes me i don't
see oh mary
all i see every week online is why isn't
she on the trip
why isn't she on the snowmobile why
isn't she there with them for this i
would love to see mary doing xyz
people want to see you yes i always say
i have beauty in all my mess
the reality is that i am married to my
grandmother's
second husband which was my
step-grandfather
before she passed she made it very clear
that she wanted me to be the one
to take her place don't think it wasn't
weird cause it was
but i did it because i trusted my
grandmother
and i'm so glad i did it obviously going
going into the season in your home life
people took a lot of interest and it was
a topic of discussion all season long
how do you feel now that everybody knows
everything
good i feel really good i feel relieved
i feel um this is mary
and you you set mary in her life or you
don't
and i didn't see this coming i didn't
you know oh i want to grow up and i want
to be a house
but like that's not my childhood dream
life just kind of takes you where you're
supposed to go
and so it's up to you to follow it this
felt good so right so i
i'm like well people think i'm weird
they stay behind my back they talk about
my back let me just tell them in their
face
this is mary and yes i'm married to my
grandmother's
ex-husband how about that
how does um robert senior feel about
your business now being
everybody's business he kind of trusts
me
it's a reunion you'll really get a
really sense of
robert senior because he says something
that just like
makes complete sense and everyone will
understand
i love it so okay so he had your back
that day he was there to fight for you
yes of course yeah that he was there
i like to see it i like to see it i love
you came into this season
i watched that ig live you did with
theresa judice and you said have any
skeletons in your closet
i came in with no skeletons i i'm out i
mean
all right and the thing is if you do
think they're going to come
out so just be you know be aware i do
want to clear the air on some things
that are floating around about you some
accusations allegations
that we're not on the show but people
want answers
okay people seem to be confused about
where your money comes from what is the
income
coming well i mean mostly i i that's why
we said blessed but we do have a copying
company business
it's called kings copies and we do a lot
of like
billboards and different you know
business card we can do anything we can
make shopping bags we do
bags for a lot of department stores but
it's not like i just have
money coming out of the walls these
things that i have
or collect your pieces people don't even
remember they're so old
and i just take care of my things and i
always say you're blessed
when you know where everything comes
from yeah and i do
yeah like there's no dirty money leading
you
to where you are i i can't live like
that
yeah i can't live like that no
that leads me into the other allegation
is that you live
off of money given to your church
that's so cool i mean it's and it's i
feel like it's so judgmental because i'm
i am african-american and and a woman
and i do have an eye for
finding things in life i have
intelligent church members
and they're you know they're not gonna
get they know that
what's oh to god we do believe it ties
an offering and what's old
you know they're not gonna just give me
god's money
and i'm not gonna take it i would never
do that i'm so now
in it for the money oh my goodness like
i believe in what i what i what i do i
believe in what i'm saying
and i i love my church and i love what's
there and
i believe in it i don't i don't get
money can't fulfill that
not for me i need i need more i think
something's not going to run out
yeah something that's not tangible um
there was some speculation that you
don't actually preach at your church
that you only did it for the show
that's not true i don't know why i have
so many haters i don't know
they're like coming out of the woodwork
and they they waited 22 years to start
saying all these things about me why
didn't they tell me this 10 years ago
the final kind of accusation allegation
out there about you is that the church
is some sort of cult they've been saying
that since
my grandmother started the church and um
they say that about pretty much every
church yeah it's no like
cult i was taught church is should be a
place where
love always flows a feeling should be
there
you should not be asleep and you should
be awoken
and you should be aware and you should
be hearing
something more powerful and higher than
wherever you are and i don't
the cold thing once people that know me
my church members
they know those those are false
allegations that's like ridiculous
so they're it's the people that are
looking for fall like clearly i'm not
gonna get on national television
be a housewife and be in a cult right
like
yeah like come on no right i believe in
my church
well i'm glad we could clear that all up
set the record straight on all fronts
all right um you owned up to on watch
evans live miss speaking
about how close you are with sharlinda
uh your family member who works with you
but i want to dig into this relationship
a little more because people notice she
serves you on a tray
and all the food is wrapped up in
plastic which is reminiscent of a
hospital mary and we know how you feel
about hospitals
i was in the hospital i never had my
food come in plastic
they rolled it in on a table like a
hotel table
no um when the show aired
sharlinda actually you know i don't know
she got the green eye
and she turned on me and she left oh wow
she lives with me rent free for
you know 20 years and and then to
turn on me it's like i really don't know
who she is it was how we were raised
that's what my grandmother did and
that's what she knew when her mom does
and that's
that's so that's it's not a thing that i
need a special
i am a germaphobic bill i don't like
germans right
but it's just this is just the thing
that's been how
he has lived forever it's not yeah i
didn't change
the way my grandmother set things up i
just
tip don't give anymore do you ultimately
regret
hospital smell that whole thing
no no no regret what do you want me to
do
not say you smell like hospital when she
gets both legs amputated
i don't know what you want me to do
about your aunt her legs are gone why
are you getting your legs cut off it's
60 that means your diet's bad
you know just like she didn't eat right
like drink water like okay
i see that it can go come across as rude
what i do regret
probably is the way i got so frustrated
i felt like i was being blamed and i
didn't know why but i just
i never said jen smells like hospital i
said
merit it smells like hospital can you
please go eat with me
someone took that back to jen and told
her that i said she said if that's why i
kept trying to find out who told her
but no one will tell me who told her
okay
but she sounds like there are still
lingering questions after the reunion
mary we didn't even get all the answers
to everything it sounds like
[Laughter]
some things you just like it is what it
is you know
it but the end of the day it's a kind of
the dig
you smell like hospital no i mean it is
it's an iconic it's an iconic bravo
quote at this point so it's like it goes
down in history good
bad indifferent fashion has been a big
part of your story on this show
do you have a favorite look you got to
wear
on the first season probably the fashion
show
for fashion week in park city when jen
just
gave me this cat eye
yeah i knew i was fierce how is the
high-end hoarding situation going did
you wind up getting a separate
apartment or condo for your clothes are
you still living surrounded by racks and
racks and racks no i did not
buy a apartment for my clothes which
that would be so luxury
to do oh just walk in and but no like
no i have not done that um i just kind
of gotten more organized and i've done
it myself
and i'm getting there just giving me any
prayers
he's my peace all right this i mean an
apartment closet
might be a great thing to showcase in a
second season mary
do you want to come back for another
season would you do this again
i don't know if i'd do this again why do
you say that what makes you say that
i just don't know that's a strong
question and it i needed i think i need
a little bit
harvesting i think it's premature but i
don't
i mean would they want me back i think
that
i think they will want you back but it
sounds like maybe you want to take a
breath you need some space away
you filmed it it's air you want to take
a breath before you figure out the next
step yeah yeah that that that's always
important
to just regroup especially when you got
attacked and
you know i i toughened up i've gotten
tougher you know
so i can tell no i can tell ah
all right well before we get to season
two before we even get to this reunion
there are still a couple
episodes of season one left to air what
do you want the fans to know about these
last couple of episodes
hang in there i'm on one
i love it yeah i i i think just
yeah i'm coming and i'll we're going out
with a name i guess
[Music]
you